Hello world.
It's a Raj and mx net.
It's Amazon's deep learning library.
It's right up there with tensorflow
and cafe as one of the most used deep
learning libraries out there.
And this video,
I'm going to build a very simple neural
network using mx net and I'm going to go
over all the different parts of its
Api so you could see how it works.
It's got this imperative Api,
it's got a distributed
training done really well.
And what we're going to do
is talk about its features,
compare it to other deep
learning frameworks,
and then start writing some code in python
in this stupid or notebook that I've
got up.
So an overview of mx net.
It was founded by a couple
of universities. Uh, it's,
it supports pretty much any time.
I mean it says here's CNNS and Lstm,
but you can really make any type of neural
network that's been discovered so far
with mx net. Uh, it
scalable so it to flow.
But one thing that it has a
tensor flow does not have,
is multilanguage support specifically
for a scholar and for our,
and then for a few other languages
that we're going to look at. Uh,
it's got a vibrant ecosystem both
in academia and in the industry.
We have some examples of companies that
are using mx net right here in this
picture right here. Baidu for
example, a University of Alberta.
And why you Intel, uh,
and then for its features,
I just kind of like screenshot
of this from the mx net website,
but it's flexible. I mean that's just
kind of a generic term. Let's be real.
It's portable. Okay. So it runs on CPU
or Gpu? Yes. Sounds good so far. Uh,
right. We talked about multiple
languages, auto differentiation.
What that means is that you can use
this to perform gradient descent
automatically with a single function call.
So it is tends to flow,
so it does a lot of the other libraries,
but it has this,
it's distributed on the cloud.
So it's actually very easy to
distribute your computation.
And we're going to talk about that more
so than I would say even tensorflow.
And then performance wise,
it's pretty damn fast.
I mean I've looked on the
web and I've seen several uh,
performance metrics like from several
articles of comparing mx nets performance
versus tensorflow. And when it
comes to bigger, bigger datasets,
mx net tends to outperform tensorflow.
So, which is interesting, but you know,
because tensorflow has so
much activity on get hub,
like more so than any other deep learning
framework yet mx net performance,
better at scale in terms of datasets.
Uh,
here's his other great comparison
graph comparing the top, you know,
seven frameworks to each other based
on a, you know, a series of metrics,
but then notice how yeah,
mx net really excels when
it comes to multiple GPU
support. Uh, that's really the,
the, the main thing and we're going to
go into that in code. If we look at this,
a chart here of AI frameworks
and then AI infrastructure,
mx net was really built with AWS in mind.
So if you plan on using AWS,
mx net is probably the way to go just
because it works so well with AWS.
You've got these prebuilt ams that are
machine images that you can just preload
into an AWS instance,
like an [inaudible] or a GPU instance.
And then whatever you're running with
mx net does tends to work more often,
get less errors and if you're
using other frameworks,
so then right down to tensorflow versus
mx net, forget the other frameworks.
They're both multi Gpu Mxn is distributed,
tens of is not.
This is actually changed.
So tensorflow is all distributed now.
However mx net makes it easier to do.
So they're both mobile friendly. Okay.
So now onto its really its core
features that that I really liked.
The first one is the fact
that it has an imperative API,
like compared to tensorflow,
it's got this imperative APIs.
You might be wondering what
are you talking about here?
So this is an example of imperative
programming, right? Okay.
So what we're doing here is imperative
programming is a way to say,
define by run.
What that means is we're going to define
the parts of this computation graph
that we're building. Like these
are, these are two matrices.
We multiply them together and then we
can add, add other operations to that.
So Pi Torch is another example
of an imperative framework,
but then declarative
programming is defined and run.
So we define the variables first,
then we run it.
The problem is that this is
a static computation graph.
It can't change over time, right? So you
define your variables, your operations,
and then you run the program.
This means that if you have
something like what say,
let's say a recurrent network,
a recurrent network works better
with a declarative, uh, with, sorry,
an imperative, a programming approach
because it's defined during runtime.
So any of the newer,
deep learning models,
they use these features that
are real time. So you know,
data is changing in real time.
So that's why something like Pi Torch
works better than tensorflow because
intention flow, you define the graph,
then you run it. Oh, with Pi torture,
with Amex Net, you define the graph and
then it can modify itself. It's not a,
it's not an immutable graph. It's
mutable. So it changes over time,
which is good for a lot
of the newer models.
The big con of this is that
it's hard to optimize. You know,
there were some early on decisions that
the tensorflow team May to say this is
going to be a declarative
language framework.
And the reason was because it was
just easier to optimize. However,
as the deep learning space
progressed over time,
we found that imperative programming
was a better model for these real time
changing models.
These to cast tech models,
like one example would be
variational auto encoders.
So then onto the mixed
programming paradigm, right?
This is an example of how
Amex net actually does both.
So you can go full imperative if you,
if you'd like,
or you could use this symbolic execution,
that declarative execution.
So you had that option. However, most
people, if you look at mx net code on,
on get hub, most of it is imperative.
So that's it for the explanation.
And let's just start coding
this thing, right? So, uh,
I'm going to go over three
different features that I'm
going to go over the Ndra
Api. I'm going to go over the module Api
and then I'm going to go over the, uh,
symbol Api.
Okay.
So these are the three really the
main parts of the mx net framework.
So we can install it with this very simple
command. Pseudo, so that installs it.
The simple line right here,
make sure you have Sudo installs.
So the NDRA API is a core
data structure for mx net.
It represents a multidimensional array,
an end dimensional array. And this,
this enables imperative computation.
It executes code leisurely,
allow me to automatically parallelize
multiple operations across the available
hardware.
So this is good for neural
networks because neural
networks are operating on end
dimensional data rights. So if
you have a single feature, right,
that's one dimension. If you had a
second feature that's two dimensions.
If you had a third feature that's three
dimensions and you can keep going, right?
You know,
you can have a car's tire length and its
speed and its philosophy and its shape
and all these things,
you know,
so it's a multidimensional data structure
that we're inputting into a neural
networks.
You could think of all of these features
as dimensions and you can just think of
a single data points, right?
A single car, for example,
as a giant matrix or an
end dimensional array.
And so the way that, uh,
mx had deals with this is,
it calls it the end d array API.
And so there's an image of a,
a handwritten character.
If you break it down,
it's really just a two dimensional array
of numbers. If you add color to it,
then it's a three dimensional array
and et cetera, et Cetera, et cetera.
So let's start coding this so we
could see, you know how this works.
So what I'll do is I'll create this nd
array and I'll say it's going to have
an a,
it's going to have a two dimensional,
a data structure.
Okay.
And so now I can say a dot size six.
So it's got six different data
points inside of that nd array.
I can also say,
Hey dot shape.
So it's a two by three nd array object,
right?
So he's got two data points and inside
there are three different data points
inside of there. So it's two by three
dimensions. Okay. So then we can say
we can even customize the,
um,
we can customize what it holds.
So we can say using non pies,
a dependency which is made from
h matrix math. We can say, uh,
let's say we've got that same object,
right?
So let's just copy and paste that in here.
It's that same object
and we're going to define the data
type has numb pies into 32 data type.
And then we'll say, well, what does
that data type that we just defined?
And it's going to say in 32.
Now if we want to print it,
we can say what is inside of this object?
And then it prints it out.
Uh,
we can also perform a series of
matrix operations on it very easily.
If I just say, um, let me
just copy that back over here.
The equals,
I'll call it a equals.
Okay. I'll say B equals
a times a. So there's,
there's are a element wise,
matrix multiplication
and then be as num Pi.
Tell us what's inside of be very easily.
And there we go.
So if we wanted to do
something like a dot product,
if we want to do a dot product,
then we can say something like, uh,
let's say we have the same object here
and then we say B is going to be the
transpose of a right now
and let's do a dog product.
So we're going to use the NDRA API APIs
dot function using both of our matrices.
And then we can say, well what did we
just get using the as num Pi function?
Okay.
And it's saying uh,
mx.
Oh yeah, right. Duh. There we go.
So we can also define the,
what we want it to run on.
Like we could say we want it to run on
the CPU, we want it to run on the GPU,
et cetera. Right? So right
now we're just saying CPU,
but we can really have it run on
any type of hardware, CPU, Gpu,
and we can define that right here and
I'll just run that. Just like that. Okay.
So that's it for the Ndra Api. Now
let's talk about the symbol Api. Okay.
So this is a symbolic graph,
right?
If you've ever visualize a computation
graph using tensor board or any of those
tools, you'll see that it
looks like a graph like this,
right? Well, it's happening.
Are these tensors are flowing through
these computation, um, these operators,
right? So it's saying, take this
data point, take this data point,
apply some matrix multiplication to it,
and take that output and then, you know,
keep performing all
these operations to it.
And this is essentially a neural
network. It's a computation graph. So,
okay,
here's an example of, of,
of what this looks like.
So instead of doing it to the imperative
way, we can do it the declarative way,
which is very similar, similar to
tensorflow, if we'd like to write.
So it depends on your use case.
If you're doing a static, um,
if you're doing a perceptron,
a feed forward neural network,
you'd want to use a static,
um, computation graph.
If you're doing a recurrent
network and LSTM network,
then you'd probably want to
use the imperative a style.
So this here's a stall for both of them.
So let's see what else we can do here.
So if we say I'm a, let's
just, let's just see what,
what's contained inside of
these variables. So we say run,
we can see that these are all nd arrays.
So we could see everything that's stored
inside of them and he was a result of
all of those operations. And there we
go. We've got all of that there as well.
But what type of a variable is,
well,
it's an Ndra have an nd
array of an India Ray. Okay,
three dimensions. So now, um, we'll say,
well, what are the arguments
to eat? Like what makes up e?
So we use the list arguments
function on that.
So be consistent a, B, c, and d.
And we can say, okay, so now let's,
um,
list the outputs.
So what it says is that he depends
on variables a, B, c, and d,
that the operation that computes he is
a sum and that he is indeed a B plus CD.
And so we can do much more
than just plus or minus.
We can do multiplication and division
and a lot of different operations,
but those are the ones that we're
doing right here. So now if we,
like if we,
if we want to bind data to operations,
we can do that using a binding. Okay.
So let's say we've got this data, right?
We've got four different data points.
They're all of type in 32 and what we
want to do is we want to bind each MD or
nd array to its corresponding symbol.
So to do that we're going to have to
initialize an executer. So an executer,
okay,
is e. Dot. Bind? It was, we're
going to bind together on the CPU,
several different variables with a,
we're going to bind the
variable a to whatever's in aid,
a data and then hold on.
And then
B
to whatever's in B data.
I also want to bind.
See,
and I also want to bind
d.
There we go. So that's our
executer and we can say, well,
what's in this executer?
And he'll tell us what,
you've got an executer
object. Great. So now we can,
we can let our input data
flow through the graph.
And the way we're going to do that,
or it's going to say,
well he data is going to,
we're going to use the x,
we're going to use a forward
function of the executer.
And that's going to afford all that
data through that computation graph,
using the executer as the medium
to do that. And then we can say,
well what do we got an e now and that
it's got this result 14 that's the result
of all of those computations
that we performed.
Okay? So the last bit is the module Api.
Now we can build our neural network. Okay,
so to build our neural network,
we're going to do this. Okay?
So what we're gonna do is we're going
to build a neural network that will
predict a co a class or category,
like 10 different ones from a sample of
a thousand different datas data points.
Okay. So these are imaginary data
points and we can import these directly.
So the first thing we're going to do
is obviously in port our dependencies,
and then we're going to say, oh,
we want a thousand data points.
We want 800 of them to be for training.
We have,
we want the rest to be for testing.
Here's how many features are
going to be 10 categories.
And with a batch size of 10.
So every training and a rash iteration,
we're training our model on 10
different data points every time. Okay.
So now we can generate our dataset.
So to generate our Dataset,
or we're going to use the
uniform function of, uh,
the Ndra Api.
And to do that unit form
below equal zero Pi equals
one shape equals sample count,
feature account.
And then we can print it out and
see what we've just created. And
Oh, not Emek am decks. And
so that tells us, okay,
you've created a data point.
It's, you know, it's got,
it's using this uniform distribution.
So it's just generating all these points
randomly according to some distribution.
And then we have that and
to generate our categories,
we'll just iterate through that, uh, this
random number generator and say, okay,
these are going to be our categories
for each of these integers.
Then to split our dataset into training
and testing, we'll split the data,
right? We're going to use a crop
function to crop the data in half or not,
not in half. 80, 20. It's
gonna be an 80, 20 split. Okay,
so now we can build the network.
So here's what it looks like.
It's very similar to
carrots or tensor flow.
You're defining this neural network by
first initializing it with this data
variable. You're saying, well, we want the
first layer to be fully connected, right?
So a single layer
corresponds to a single line.
It's got 64 neurons in that layer.
So every neuron in that layer is going
to be connected to the next layer.
We'll add this activation function
relu or rectified linear unit,
a very popular type of activation
function, another fully connected layer,
a soft max output, which is
essentially an activation function.
And then we output the result
to this mod a variable. Now, uh,
we can indeed inner iterate
on the Dataset, 10 samples
and 10 labeled at a time.
And then we're going to call
reset to restore the iterator
to its original state.
But we have to initialize this iterator.
Okay, so we need to build an iterator.
That's, that's what we have to do
so that we can train in batches.
That's what iterators or for. So here's
our iterator and it's going to say, well,
train on the x data, the wide data
and with the batch size being batch,
which we defined up here,
10 and then we'll say,
train the model using this bind function,
here's the optimizer,
go for it. And that's it. I
already initialize my optimism
miser before. So it's,
it's taking a while,
but basically this runs in like
10 seconds and then that's it.
That's it for the mx and an API.
I hope you found this video useful.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to research some deep learning
frameworks, so thanks for watching.